I want you to read about resistance I
want you to really get into what the
[ __ ] resistance is resistance is
invisible and it once you read that and
you understand where you how your mind
works
you know when it broke it down like I
said when I read the Anthony Robbins
thing a lot of that made sense but a lot
of it was repetitively that it's gonna
stick her and [ __ ] and thirty percent of
the time and don't stick this [ __ ]
sticks if you look at the write on
writing sticks this [ __ ] sticks with you
and this is you know man I get a
thousand [ __ ] emails a day Thank You
Dante cos Eenie always sends emails I
read his letters but they got a lot of
emails from people on different Gmail
accounts his [ __ ] and people stuck
people are [ __ ] stuck now again bro
get a notebook
start writing it down you want to get
off those pills you want to get off that
heroin you want to get off to blow it
took me a year right and how much I
ain't in [ __ ] life for me to finally
get off to powder and I know that 20% of
it was the [ __ ] I was writing in that
notebook I looked at that notebook three
years later and I'm not just threw it
away I'll I don't know push you just
throw away okay I ripped the covers off
it like cut each page with scissors and
such tiny things cuz I never wanted
anyone to ever read what I went through
that year before I quit cocaine the
things that were on that paper were the
truth a lot of truth which isn't pretty
that's like it but that's really
differently well you went and like you
made this you cut every page every
January I would start every January one
I would get two notebooks because I know
I would go through two notebooks I would
name him that year okay and in 2007 a
year I got off blow uh-huh
I threw that notebook away when I moved
to the valley which was 2009 and when I
read I was like maybe I'll keep this
maybe I'll keep this who knows and when
I started reading it I said Eileen do I
not want to keep this I don't want to
see this again because this was
Appert if somebody read this just by
reading this they give this to the
authorities and make them come get me
just to do a slight they probably take
my shoelaces and [ __ ] put me in a
black cell I swear to God 5150 or
whatever that is [ __ ] I was writing that
blows last eight months before that
summer when I was doing heroin Oh the
[ __ ] I would write at night when I was
doing heroin was so sad was just my
bitter guts of what I thought about
myself while I was doing the drug you
know and then it got goofier than goofy
or how I was gonna stop snorting coke by
doing the heroin and then when I but
then it was that [ __ ] weekend in
November and then if you look at the
week before I quit coke instead of
writing a page and a half I was writing
like four pages this is how you woman
bro everything this is crazy I never
needed all this you have to write when
you wake up in the morning and then
midday you have to finish the other side
of the page and explain how your day
went when your expectations were what
you didn't really do if you really stick
to this and you keep three years at a
time and you look back and you [ __ ]
will thrown away unless you're just like
gambling and making millions or you're
in the stock market but to see the guts
what you were writing when you were
struggling is something that's I would
never publish it
even now I look at like I look at in
July I look at next [ __ ] last year's how
honest are you in them like is it hard
to be brutally honest do you lie to
yourself
whoo I'm like you know then that memoirs
and that's not a diary with a locked on
it you knows I remember 20 years people
I write in my diary every day and then
everybody would steal your [ __ ] diary
and you crack and people would steal
your diary and you'd be in there talking
about you like [ __ ] candy canes or
something no this is when I wake up in
the morning my morning writing is about
when I wake up in the morning if a man
got about something I write it out and
why I should be Enya and how would
resolve the situation early in the
morning you will wake up angrily saya
yes this is what you do oh my god
and it's a lot better if you smoke a
joint this morning I didn't wake up
angry I woke up really rested and when I
started writing this morning I when I'm
fired because I don't know why once I
saw mercy and I started talking to my
wife and drank some coffee and I was
gone [ __ ] bananas but I've been
sticking to my writing plan six days a
week two paragraphs a damn and sticking
to it man and it's only it just pops up
it's the way this thing it just pops up
now it took me four years a [ __ ]
writing to get to this and if you read
the war of I it that's what it tells you
we need it pop so make sure you sit down
and write every day it took me four
years now now for some reason little it
boom next thing you know I got one
paragraph down next thing you know I'm
blending the two paragraphs together
next thing you know I had a third one
next thing I look at the clock it's
10:00 to 5:00 let me add my sentences
for tomorrow let me start the outline
for tomorrow and boom I close the
computer I'm done for the [ __ ] day
and the next day I have my day
proportion so I know exactly what I'm
gonna hit that [ __ ] thing it's really
weird how it doesn't become an addiction
but it becomes an automatic response now
just because I read that stupid war of
art because I wasn't sitting down that
book forced me to sit down stop
bullshitting yourself the only way
you're gonna learn to write is by
writing the only way you're gonna write
your goals is by writing your goals
every day so you find the niche in your
day and you write at that niche and also
you get like I wouldn't write
book in the morning when I wake up my
head's too [ __ ] up there's no way so
in the morning I write jumps that's from
my head's [ __ ] off that's how I want
to write a joke well it's not really me
it's somebody else that woke up after 22
thousand milligrams anibal's and an
anxiety pill and [ __ ] joints and I
swang a bat and a protein powder but
you're not fighting yourself I'm trying
to write it at night at 10:00 p.m. no
I'm not chasing the goat no more no no
no no I'm not pulling away watches when
I'm eating fruit at night to beat the
[ __ ] points you knows I know that
[ __ ] that's I feel like I'm gonna get
really pissed off of myself when I don't
read this book yes the stuff that just
the time I read it a couple weeks ago I
thought a lot about you when I read this
book because we all have a were lacking
something the reason why we're not where
we are is because we're lacking a
certain element in our lives and I'm no
better than you guys this is why I read
this [ __ ] I don't read this [ __ ] because
I'm King Farouk and I'm just smart I was
fight cool alum down whatever that [ __ ]
is what are you if I couldn't alum
whatever when you the smartest person in
the school my beta cap is one yeah I
started come on a cool but I would
assume come on I wasn't any of them no I
could tell he probably went to see
[ __ ] bad santa 2